another big announcement at Gamescom
well not an announcement but we saw a
little bit more finally of crackdown 3
the long-awaited third game in that
crackdown trilogy which made such a
splash on xbox 360 how you guys feel
about crackdown jumping off buildings
grabbing the orbs
dude superhero stuff you like it yeah I
had a lot of fun with the first
crackdown I remember I think after like
called duty too it was one of the first
Xbox 360 games I played I really liked
you know you know the action based
experience where you know in order to
gain agility you have to get these coins
and that was my favorite part of the
game was being able to jump these you
know 20 story skyscrapers in one jump
and you know improving your vehicle
skills it was just fun all around and
toward the end of the game you're really
overpowered and then the fact that
they're calling it 100% destructible
environments will see you yeah what was
claimed yeah because I just imagined the
entire city being leveled they showed
them a skyscraper just kind of falling
and creating this domino effect which
potentially looks cool but I'm curious
because this was a pre-alpha footage I'm
curious how that will end up in the
final build I mean if I recall right
previous crackdown games did have some
trouble with the physics engine when
there was too much stuff going on on
screen at once but it's a really good
it's a really good concept I really love
the Red Faction series like Red Faction
gorilla in any game that channels that
level of destruction is is great in my
book and we're seeing obviously this is
pre-alpha so it doesn't you know the
detail on textures and stuff isn't that
super but like I'm gonna pay with that
like if if they're gonna actually
accomplish this kind of destructibility
like I don't need to go up and look and
see like realistic concrete picture
staring back and you like current
crackdown has always had this kind of
like vaguely stylized cartoonish kind of
look to it and I think if they lean into
that maybe they can save some processing
power on textures and stuff obviously I
have a technical there so technically
savvy I definitely understand how all
this works no but you know it's like
it's interesting to see that kind of
ambition because I think destructibility
is like this is one of the sort of new
frontiers that like graphically and
engine-wise we still there's still a lot
of room to push it also does beg the
question if everything's destructible
you know
gonna be the first guy to try and
destroy the entire map oh yeah
is that gonna happen definitely right
right away well you're gonna have to
have I think you know because they're
also talking about a multiplayer they
mentioned that multiplayer beta like
Xbox one folks are unit first access to
that in summer 2016 so you know
multiplayer that kind of destruction
well you just have a new match and it's
all back but how does that destruction
play into single-player is there even a
single-player proper campaign I don't
know like it could just be some kind of
multiplayer shared hero space where we
all just romping around fighting over
orbs and again going back to a red
faction they did have a good multiplayer
in that game where you can do fun things
like you jump on the roof of the
building somebody'd be running below you
and you just pop the roof open and then
throw a grenade in you know it's that
really cool idea if you're not safe
anywhere in anything oh yeah and the
fact that it's you know you're
superhuman cyborg police officers kind
of adds even more weight to the fact
that you might be able to destroyed
literally anything and then if you get
to use that effectively against other
human players that'll be pretty awesome
to see yeah I think that dropping a
building on someone could be pretty
delightful probably hurts slash
effective all right we'll be looking for
more on crackdown 3 as Gamescom
continues of course we're gonna be here
all week with Gamescom coverage coming
from Germany and come at you from our
offices here in San Francisco